ah too easily words of war become acts
of war we don't know the truth yet Lord
stark must be told of this
I don't trust a raven to carry these
words I'll ride to King's Landing no
there must always be a stark in
Winterfell what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones season a prediction video
today's discussion will contain spoilers
so please proceed with caution by now I
am sure most of you are aware of all the
recent spoilers that have came out from
the King's Landing set in Dubrovnik I
have made two different videos on which
I gave some of my opinions on what I
think is happening there but I know a
lot of you had questions about these
recent developments so I wanted to take
the time today to answer some of those
questions the first question is from s
Davis Cersei doesn't look pregnant and
this is supposed to be episode five what
do you think as Davis is referring to
the most recent photos of Cersei and Jon
Snow standing together on set at the end
of season seven Cersei was still
claiming to be pregnant but in these
photos she does not appear to be showing
any signs yet just to clarify these
photos aren't from Episode five these
will most likely be from episode four
since David Nutter is the one seen in
some of these photos as well if Cersei
truly was pregnant you would think she
would be showing signs of having a baby
bump near the end of next season I think
the answer to this question is fairly
simple before season seven even ended I
was saying Cersei will have a
miscarriage and I still stand by that
statement Cersei will never be able to
have children again
in fact Cersei should have had this
miscarriage in this season 7 finale but
they apparently are saving this for next
season the entire plot leaked last
season in 99.5% of everything that was
in that leak came true except for one
thing and that was Circe's miscarriage
the lake said she would wake up in a bed
of blood during her last scene of the
season and obviously that didn't happen
but I am very confident it will happen
next season Cersei will lose her baby at
the beginning of season 8 and that's why
she doesn't appear to be
pregnant in these photos the next
question is from Gambino capo will we
finally see how and read I know this is
something a lot of people want to know
especially ever since the new photos
came out people believe the man standing
next to Jon Snow is Howland Reed but I
have to say I completely disagree I
don't think he looks anything like
Howland Reed nor does his clothes look
like something the chronic men would
wear other than that I would say there
is maybe a 25% chance we will see
Howland Reed again as of right now I
don't see what purpose he would serve at
this point I no longer think we need
Howland Reed to confirm Jon Snow's
parents people in the north are already
taking brands word
they killed Littlefinger based mostly
when the things brain said he saw so if
they're willing to take his word for
that then they should believe him when
he says who Jon's mother and father is
Plus Sam has a record of regard getting
an annulment and getting married again
they could probably connect the dots
between those records and what bran says
the only way I could see them bringing
back Howland Reed now as if he is
important in terms of the endgame he
would need to serve some kind of a
purpose to pay him to appear in the last
season there haven't been any casting
calls for a man with his description and
they aren't even bringing back mirror
Reed so I think it's very unlikely but
like I said I will give it a 25% chance
because you never know I would like to
see Howland Reed again but I haven't
seen anything that would indicate we
will the next question is from skeleton
king do you think Jon would be ballsy
enough to go to King's Landing alone I
know the meme is he's a pretty boy who
doesn't put much thought into things but
I don't know I think more people are
there that just haven't been spotted yet
even if it is to confront Cersei on
betraying them I don't think he'd go do
that alone even if he just wants to talk
based on what we have seen Jon do in the
past
I absolutely believe he would be ballsy
enough to go alone there are more than
enough examples that prove jon is either
crazy enough or stupid enough to do
something like this
what are you doing I promise moment I'll
never lose it again
in case they don't come back I didn't
come all this way to have my hand
murdered I've don't wants us to murder
me either
I could have stated my cell and saved a
great deal of trouble I did this I
should go have definitely murder you as
you can see John has done things like
this before even in this season 7 finale
he wanted to go talk to Cersei alone but
on the other hand I believe the second
part of what you said is more likely to
happen Jon may be seen talking to Cersei
alone right now but I highly doubt he
went all the way to King's Landing by
himself there is no way they would allow
their king to put himself in this much
danger not if they could help themselves
when John had done [ __ ] like this in the
past
he wasn't the king yet and when he went
beyond the wall he didn't have enough of
his own men around him to stop him but
if Jon goes from Winterfell to King's
Landing next season they're not gonna
allow him to travel alone it would be
way too dangerous and everyone knows you
can't trust Cersei so I think you are
right John does have some companions
with him but they aren't on the set yet
but they will start popping up soon
enough this next question is from bianca
funk in regards to Winterfell being up
in flames do you think the night King
was able to take Winterfell because the
night king is a stark himself just to
clarify I'm not talking about bran being
the night king but I mean he's one of
those Starks from the past this is one
hell of a question Bianca and I am glad
you asked me this I was actually gonna
make a video that related to this
question I believe the possibilities of
this being true are very high now I know
the night king from the show in the
night's king from the books or two
different characters but the one from
the show was inspired by the one created
in the books they never would have
thought of making the night king in the
show if George didn't already place the
building blocks for this character in
the books the night's king in the book
is a stark and I have always believed
the night king in the show as a stark -
I know he didn't have the dark hair
colour like most Starks do but over time
not all of the Starks carried the same
exact traits anyway I think they just
simply used the same actor that was
already wearing
the night Kings makeup and costume to
save themselves from having to hire a
new actor plus we already know you can't
put too much stock into hair color
anyway John has black hair but we know
he's a legitimate Targaryen so just
because the night king has sandy brown
hair or whatever color that is it
doesn't mean he's not a Stark I know
some of you have your own beliefs but I
can only answer this according to how I
feel so just for the sake of this
question let's say the night king is a
stark I think that would explain why the
night king has a strong connection to
bran Stark and that could also explain
why the night king seems to be taking
interest in Jon Snow what if the night
Kings goal is to take back Winterfell if
this night king is an old Stark from the
past he may feel like he has the right
to rule the north in Winterfell more
specifically he may have been the ruler
of Winterfell and the north from the
past and his goal could be to reclaim
his seat of power the crypts of
Winterfell were full of kings of winter
and those kings of winter are said to
have eyes of ice Ned Stark dreams about
this he would fill the eyes of ice
staring at him while he was down there
Jon Snow also has dreams of the crypts
and the old kings of winter are always
telling Jon he does not belong there
what if all those kings of winter are
former night kings and they are telling
Jon he doesn't belong there because this
new night king is the rightful ruler of
House Stark maybe that's what the night
King is coming back to take if he has a
stark then Winterfell is his home think
about what happened when the night king
brought down the wall when his army went
marching through east watch many people
believe the night king's army was in the
shape of a direwolf and i have to be
honest it does kind of look like the
stark sigil of a direwolf that could be
a big clue as to who the night king is
and where he is heading the Starks are
obviously connected to the others in
some way their house words are winter is
coming and I always believe that is
referring to the king of winter is
coming Ned Stark's Valyrian steel sword
is called ice and that's a direct
connection to the others in fact the
name ice is older than Ned Stark's sword
itself that wasn't the first sword the
Starks had that was called ice
that name was passed down from hundreds
or even thousands of years ago it has a
deeper meaning than some of us can even
fathom right now if you want to get real
crazy it might be the only sword that is
able to slay the night king the name
could refer to it being the only thing
that can stop the ultimate symbol of ice
and that would be the night King but
just to answer your question Bianca I
would say yes the night king should be
able to take Winterfell because he is a
stark himself but as long as there is a
stark in Winterfell to oppose him then
they should be able to stop him a stark
must always remain in Winterfell because
of the king of winter is coming the next
question is from Aaron O'Donnell do you
think that Cersei kidnapping Jon could
be a way of her luring Dany into King's
Landing yes absolutely 100% if Cersei
was able to kidnap Jon Snow somehow some
way this would leave Daenerys and Jon
supporters no choice but to rescue him
they cannot allow their King to be taken
without some kind of repercussions this
is where Jaime Lannister could come into
play depending how Cersei feels about
Jaime leaving her she might be willing
to release Jon if they brought Jaime
back to her in Chains
maybe Tyrion too she would probably
trade Jon for Jaime and Tyrion but there
is no way to know right now I think it's
pretty clear that Cersei has been
deteriorating psychologically for quite
some time now and once she loses her
baby this will drive her to absolute
madness in my opinion in that case she
may never free Jon if she was able to
capture him and this could be the reason
that forces Danny's hand and ultimately
leads to Daenerys burning King's Landing
to the ground I don't want to spend too
much time speculating on this though
because as of right now there is no sign
of anything like this happening but I do
agree if Cersei capture Jon that would
be her way of getting Daenerys to come
to King's Landing I think that could
work this next question is from miss
Coleman what if Jon never makes it to
Winterfell with Daenerys like somehow he
goes back to King's Landing by force or
trap or even discovery of new
information after he arrives in white
Harbor I only ask this because I can't
see how Jon
would leave Winterfell after the attack
especially now that the night King has
Vissarion he barely made it out of
hardhome or trying to get a white
soldier well I think John has to go to
King's Landing at some point no matter
what even though they have a war against
the night King to worry about first they
still need to remove Cersei from the
capital eventually they can't allow
Cersei to continue ruling the way that
she has Cersei is no good for the realm
and she needs to be dealt with the
sooner the better the problem with these
photos coming out is it only creates
even more questions than no one can
really answer right now the only thing
all of us can do is speculate based on
what we know so far and what we believe
will happen in the future John probably
won't arrive in King's Landing until the
end of next season so technically the
night king could be dead by then like I
have said in previous videos I believe
John is in King's Landing during episode
four based on the director who has seen
on set with him episode 4 should be
right after a big battle takes place
Miguel supports Nick is directing
episode 3 and he directed Hart home so
we may see a Hart home type episode
during episode 3 in the night King may
fall in that battle which would leave
the remaining few episodes for John and
Daenerys to deal with Cersei I know some
people believe John went to King's
Landing to ask Cersei for help but I
think we should also at least consider
that maybe the night king is already
defeated by then there is only six
episodes next season and two out of
those six episodes will be big battles
most likely episode 3 and 5 since Miguel
was directing those ones I think we
could see the night King fall during one
of those battles and Cersei fall during
the other battle since the night king is
so close already he might be the first
one to go the next question is from
shado and she says if they escape
through the crypts they will have to
clear the blockage down there what do
you think they may find and will it play
a part in the Battle of Winterfell in
the depths is where the kings of winter
are buried and if Winterfell has magic
that was used to build it how could it
play a role in this battle could the
kerp section be magically protected like
a bomb shelter against the whites these
are some very good points and
interesting questions here so I will try
answer this one at a time the first part
of this question is referring to the
photos of Jon Snow and King's Landing
some people believe they may have had to
a fled Winterfell due to the night Kings
attack so what they need to clear the
blockage down in the crypts if they use
them to escape for those of you that
don't know there are several sections to
the crypts of Winterfell and there is a
section that is partially collapsed that
no one ever visits and many people
believe something could be hidden in
that part which might be true but I
don't think they necessarily have to
take that exact route to escape there
are other secret passageways they could
use to escape Winterfell if you remember
at the end of season 2 maester Luwin
told Theon about these secret tunnels
all his past crimes are forgiven we'll
make it to the wall I won't make it 10
feet past the Winterfell gates always
hidden passageways built so the Lords of
Winterfell could escape maester Luwin
was trying to help Theon escape
Winterfell before the Bolton's caught
him and did God knows what to him when
he told Theon he could sneak out of the
castle he didn't mention anything about
it being blocked off so I don't think
they would need to worry about the
collapsed portion of the crypts they
could possibly use it like a bomb
shelter if need be the crypts of
Winterfell are the oldest part of the
castle they were built before the castle
itself it is said that brain in the
Builder and the children of the forest
are the ones who made them so they could
have the same type of magic that the
wall and the three-eyed Ravens cave had
it might prevent the others from being
able to enter them the only thing is we
don't know exactly how strong this magic
still is the three-eyed Ravens cave was
destroyed and the wall was destroyed
it's also not entirely clear if brains
mark from the night King is still
working since the dragon destroyed the
wall he might be able to destroy
Winterfell in it scripts but if there is
always a stark in Winterfell they may be
able to counteract some of this magic
especially a powerful Stark like brand
but then again if the knight King is a
stark he may be able to counteract that
magic it's a very slippery slope right
here
and it's even harder to predict when all
of the rules aren't exactly clear if I
had to give a definitive answer I would
say the night king will be defeated
before he is able to completely destroy
the castle the Starks know winter is
coming and there are several of them
remaining in Winterfell now with all of
them combined I believe they will come
out on top
Ned Stark once said the winters are hard
but the Starks will endure we always
have and I believe they always will I
can't think of a better quote to end the
video on so I will end this one right
here I want to thank everyone for their
great questions and I appreciate
everyone for taking the time out of
their day to watch the video I also have
to give a huge thanks to everyone who
continues to support this channel on
patreon I love you all and I hope each
and every one of you have a great day I
will see you in the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you